[Musik]
menschen im abseits dietmar wischmeyer
klagt an heute horst seehofer
liebe mitmenschen bitte vergessen wir
nie hinter jeder politischen intrige und
jeder noch so bekloppten scheißidee
steckt immer auch ein mensch und dieser
mensch heißt meistens horst seehofer
hier wird doch nur deshalb nicht
rausgeschmissen damit die csu nach der
vergeigten bayern-wahl einen billigen
sendenhorst hat nach außen vielleicht
immer noch ein bayerisches mannsbild so
groß und stark wie zwei schweinehälften
ausübt das weiß köln eine eigene csu den
auf dem parteitag gezwungen als kreise
auf die puppe den söder anzuhimmeln
markus söder steht für stabilität
lieber markus ich danke dir markus ich
danke dir und die liebe may cause markus
markus markus söder
er ist schlicht und einfach das beste
was wir in bayern haben
[Applaus]
was tun sie neben oper doch mal fertig
freuen
seehofer der alte kaiser weiß natürlich
dass seine tage an der macht gezählt
sind
doch nichts ist so gefährlich wie ein
angeschossenes wildschwein das durchs
politische unterholz tobt crazy horst
rüstet zur letzten schlacht gegen die
mutter aller probleme gegen die eule
merkel bluten depa dorst wurzeln die
thermische wer wie die merkel mit sich
in den orkus runterziehen als letztes
großes lebensziel bevor er in den ewigen
modellbahn keller ein rücktritt ist ja
besessen von der frau wenn wir einmal
auf in ihrem büro auf der berühmten
couch wissen nicht um eine therapie
durchzuführen sondern gemütlich bei
einer tasse kaffee zu reden
dann sagt sie so unvermittelt im
gespräch horst ich habe einen platz für
mich gefunden in einer sehr schönen
einrichtung
gegen diese kanzlerin kannst du nur
verlieren keiner dis dich so gnadenlos
der merkel neulich vor kindern
wisst ihr wer horst seehofer ist nein
macht nix den namen müsste nicht mehr
merken so und nächste woche geht es bei
menschen im abseits
um den rausschmiss von andrea nahles und
die neue spd parteivorsitzende thorsten
schäfer gümbel menschen im abseits
[Applaus]
[Musik]